the jurogan experience so what's
happening with your show man what are
you doing what's the latest oh [ __ ]
you're just gonna go right for the big
ones
get in there man all right first of all
i love your show i've been loving it for
years it's fun
and i'm a giant muscle car fan so it's
right up my alley
but uh what's the latest well everybody
hold on to your hat
out there fast and loud is no more
i have exited discovery and uh i'm a
free agent
what we're gonna be doing some cool
things in 2021 and uh it just was a
perfect storm so to speak it was time
for me to uh uh expand and grow a little
bit and i'd kind of gotten to the top of
that mountain
uh be in discovery and there there
wasn't anything else for me to do there
so
wow i used uh you know this year uh to
kind of rethink
and uh reshape what i want to do in the
future and uh
so uh fast and loud no muss
geez louise hey man eight years though
and
that's a long run you know 300-ish
episodes
and uh you know that's a lot there's
only so many times you can buy a car
fix a car sell a car and it was time to
make some changes make it more fun
and uh so the stuff we've got coming out
in 2021 is gonna be
quite a blast well you know i don't want
to
let the cat out of the bag so to speak
besides the wonder woman bracelets
yeah shaking off bullets with those
yeah a lady asked me one touch because
don't just bother you when they make
noise so they only make noise when i do
this
did you tell that to her yeah it was a
good joke
uncomfortable conversation ah she
thought it was funny oh you know it was
the back of my single vice person i'm
all married now
right person yeah yeah yeah so uh yeah
we're gonna
i think i'm gonna end up doing a podcast
because uh there's not a whole lot going
on in my genre in the podcast world i
mean i know some guys are doing it and
they're doing well but
i've never been allowed to before you
know so you got to realize
that when i signed my deal with uh disco
was almost 10 years ago so social at
disco yeah
so disc so discovery didn't you know
social media didn't
even exist hardly yeah yeah so i signed
off on all media
so up to this point until literally all
media including social media
it wasn't even social media back then i
mean what was it like myspace or
something
well i was doing something on uh another
network
back in the day and they wanted to get
control of my social
media that was like part of the deal and
they thought it was just like an easy
yes
no it's not i was like you can eat [ __ ]
there's no way you could pay for it but
it was ridiculous they wanted to use it
to promote other shows on their network
correct i'm like what are you talking
about and they're like well everybody
else let's just do it i go
i have millions of followers like
there's no [ __ ] chance you're just
gonna get
access to that for free now i had the
same conversation several times
it's a weird conversation right it's
like that you know they're being
weasley like you know this is a valuable
thing you know hey no big deal richard
we just like to use your entire social
media
to uh promote a lot of other discovery
programs no big deal yeah no big deal
you're cool with that right
okay good fine here well see they try
that but uh
i couldn't post myself i couldn't do
things like of myself
for a lot of the time like if i went out
and bought a car and my camera crew
wasn't with me and so i took my camera
phone and
whatever i wanted to post about it i
wasn't able to do that you weren't
allowed
no yeah it was pretty rough but that's
ridiculous but that would just boost up
your social media which would boost up
the show
you would think so you would think that
that would be the thought that i'm going
to
uh you know help boost the show walk me
through a conversation with one of these
knuckleheads i can't
well a fake conversation pretend i can't
let's pretend it's not discovery channel
let me tell you it's uh it's called the
hoo-ha network yeah
let me tell you it's so it's so bad you
know the question would be
how how was my tenure there you know and
how well was i treated and uh
so the answer is um there's a piece of
the contract
of the contract when i exited oh that
you can't talk [ __ ] that i can't
it's up to 25 000 fine per occurrence
have you talking [ __ ] me talking [ __ ]
can i talk [ __ ] you can talk as much
[ __ ]
i love the discovery channel i would
talk [ __ ] but i watch their programs
i like it i like it too i think this is
the automotive programming could have
been a little
stronger and we wanted to make some
changes but we were just kind of stuck
in a rut
the problem is they're a business and
businesses will get away with whatever
they can get away with there's a reason
why we had to make regulations to make
sure that companies don't dump chemicals
into rivers yeah it's because there's
certain people that when they can get
away with something they'll get away
with something
so anybody that's telling you but the
problem is
it's so short-sighted anybody that's
telling you that you can't post
something on your social media
without a camera crew there the
representing discovery channel it's so
silly because
it would boost your social media the
more you post the more interesting [ __ ]
you put particularly about muscle cars
right the more the more it boosts your
social media the more people are going
to watch your show it's just
it's math it's like the the rising tide
lifts all boats
uh i agree with you 100 but uh the uh
powers that be
they were not having it it took me five
years of
literally begging to do a crossover with
uh chip foose
no and of course that episode did so
well that they all think they're uh
genius geniuses now but uh you know so i
had a good run with discovery i'm ready
for the next thing which
uh by the way if you're uh if you're a
producer or a network or a streamer out
there i'm a free agent and i would have
to say i might be a very big free agent
[Laughter]
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience